hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play lost the lights and we're out
there a second
shut up guy I'm not scared of you I got
a barrel ha ha
oh there's oh there was goodie back
there all right
it pays to go on a rampage I'm sure
about anyone whoo oil wow there's all
sorts of goodies around here thought I
would totally would have missed but
anyway I got some sort of key or
something I forget that was the guy and
I just like you know just okay but I'm
okay now
no I'm okay who's down there door yeah
yeah yeah what did I get
I don't even know I need to find a key
to open this blade door but I have a key
right here is it the door that I'm I
need to open no okay all right um the
weird cell door I got a strange feeling
about it okay back this way you know
like oh hey
No ah to brave to brave to brave Emma my
sanity I could think I got these sanity
potions fly headache up not even a
little bit of a problem
aha was this dead body yeah that's scary
shut up ooh chair chair protect me you
didn't protect me well before but just
try please just try nothing can harm me
shut up shut up which cell door was it I
don't even know hey said weird cell
doors so I'm assuming that it's one that
oh this no this no that just opens up
what am I what's going on here weird so
door bodies yeah sorry it's stepping all
over you
okay went out what the hell I'm going
into big circle
open up I said open don't be trolling me
are you okay is there anything in here
laudanum laudanum
is that it anything behind here over
here
no okay I guess all right nothing in
here by the looks of it no all right um
not that yeah
golly I've got this okay this is where I
was this is where this weird door is I
was assuming that the weird door meant
this but no well then there another way
down here hang on I know there was I
know there had to be is where I came
from
Oh up here shut up guy suck oh damn it
it must have been one of those cell
doors on the block oh stop crying and
suck it up turn into your man card oh no
it must have been that way because I I
should have realised the event where the
bodies popped up obviously man I was
supposed to go back this way um ah now
I'm wasting oil yeah I just got like try
every one of these doors or CELTA no no
no I won't opens cuz I closed that one
don't opens ah ah no oh was that where
the guy was probably uh-huh it's saying
strange cell door and I'm like strange
whoa lose where I came in
okay so I came in from knowing opens
just fine and dandy nothing scary here
this one this one looked kind of strange
ah oh it feels almost like that cell is
calling me I need to find a key to open
it damn it I need to find a key to open
this bloody door
cuz Hillbillies say bloody
hello ah why it was Oh why it was me I
didn't do anything
it was C man C man lied about my murder
I didn't kill him
it was C man why didn't they believe me
and now they let me rot and die to
whoever is reading this no please find
him and kill him huh what's happening to
me
[Music]
yeah no all right all right then huh huh
ah it's like penumbra they're deleting
the walls uh walls are still there
technically I need a lamp Oh chair Oh
golly good golly
Oh Oh what up on the table can't get me
come terror chair oh boy oh boy they
deleted the floor
okay uh Jeremy please come here
chair chair oh my god car open no okay
all right all right you [ __ ] what's
going on here this house the key all
right
right what Oh chair come here Oh God
Oh what the hell was that all right what
what's going on here am I supposed to go
back now
well whatever
going on here was that door hinges haha
oh come on no enough with uh the
disappearing monster scares all right
whatever
all right what no no no no no no no not
nah this is wrong
you're so wrong you're so wrong oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh my god Lee up close
all right I'm okay
get out of the way I said oh my god you
gotta be joking me oh come on oh I'm so
strong I'm so strong
wait did did the monster know oh you
can't kill me
[Music]
and I'm back
and there's the naked dead guy fantastic
why why did I do Oh finally I can get
out but from to where I'm guessing the
weird door maybe I don't know I'm not
exactly sure I've a feeling that they're
not gonna let me out just just a small
feeling that would make you way too easy
you Doyle what is this
this has same room I was in oh there's a
different one
oh this was with the chest with nothing
in it okay yeah hide me hide me find me
oh oh [ __ ] you
I'm not looking at ya
so ugly fat up better to do have no
friends go away you're socially awkward
at parties okay okay
why are you still there okay all right
come on guy don't have all day
you got a move move yo fat flabby behind
sandy bush come on now Selena Jim
slimming Jim
come on see you even in this room he's
not even in this room he must have been
patrolling outside or something oh but
how the heck do I get past him then
Oh keys right there Frick and frack
maybe if I distract him look over there
there's a barrel it's a big circle
why's it have to open this way why why
why [ __ ] my life
ah come on back here ah fine whatever
I'm going the other way
fine fine finest urbis is this place
I can't even oh you got to be joking me
I can't fine fine fine whatever
come here chair are you so come with me
the barrel didn't even do anything y'all
didn't even faze him come on gamma are
you still there got my hot no you're
gone so I thought go got blood got my
way ha oh [ __ ] everything is collapsing
I need to run you didn't need to tell me
that I can't even see stop flashing stop
flashing
why is everything all of a sudden
collapsing okay alright okay I see it I
see it I see it
this is a tense situation I got I gotcha
can't see with you flashing like that
cannot see please don't people with
epaulette epilepsy please turn away oh
boy there and we're out all right here
we go what hello shiny was that water
okay
oh yeah Lee hahaha damn what a collapse
the collapse was so suddenly well put
Daniel well I bet I shouldn't be ragging
on the sky for such bad English you'd
probably not because native language or
anything like that anyway that's all the
time we got for this episode thank you
guys so much for watching and as always
I will see you in the next part bye-bye